so let me tell you where the next
trillion dollar companies are coming
from so think about chat GPT et cetera
as kind of the engine or the platform of
the internet all of these companies were
built on top of that base layer and so
the AI that starts to figure out how to
diagnose medical conditions faster
better cheaper than Physicians can
trillion dollar business the people who
can gather all of the data of all of the
sales calls and then feed them into
their AI we'll have a consistent
sustained competitive Advantage because
they will always have more information
than the guy who starts later than them
and so the idea is you want to start
that data flywheel as fast as you can so
that you can build that mode that makes
your sales AI better than anyone else's
and that is where huge amounts of
economic value are going to be created
in this short to medium term